Now that we've gone over Blueprints and UMG,
let's get started with our workshop.
Now, the goals of this workshop is
to create a simple driving game.
We're going to implement a game time limit.
We'll build a reusable pickup objects.
And we will create some UMG display and menus.
So again, we're going to make a full game loop,
if you will.
And we're going to sprinkle in our UMG
and show you how we can connect, but more importantly,
connect and talk to our UMG with our objects in our project.
Now, to get us started, what I want everybody to do
is go ahead and create a new project
using the vehicle template.
Now, I'm using Unreal Engine 5.3.
This tutorial has been updated in Reflex
using that version of Unreal.
If you're using an earlier version
or a future version of Unreal, please
know if things don't work, try this in 5.3.
And you should have success.
Other things, again, we want the vehicle template right here.
Also make sure that we have our starter content enabled.
And go ahead and hit Create.
And let's go ahead and open up that project
once that's done.